april
you're like an angel with no wings
so like a person
come on
oh god now i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
what are you doing andy i'm getting
healthier snacks for the shoeshine stand
chris is a food genius
did you know that the food you eat
becomes energy yeah
boom that's spaghetti
nachos
it's a cookie
that's my husband
okay if you're allergic to any food
we'll know in a few days i think based
on the redness i might be allergic to
getting stabbed by needles we have
already been to like five different
doctors uh i got my ankles microwaved
x-rayed they took my blood away to use
for science cholesterol tests april had
her sinuses removed looked at some guy
looked at my wiener touched it that was
weird and that guy wasn't even a doctor
that
what i'm retiring from music andy andy
done but not without burst a monster
farewell performance solo on this stage
tonight everybody i'ma show these idiots
what a big mistake they made i need a
piece of paper i need a pen i need four
more beers i need a computer fan i need
a lightning bolt of inspiration it's
songwriting time what do you need a
computer fan for sometimes when you use
a computer it gets hot
and the fan cools down
oh
i feel right at home as a shoe shine i
have no idea what i'm doing but i know
i'm doing it really really well
scenario a high school-aged child asks
to hold your service revolver what do
you do yes
i gave it to him when i was a kid i
always wanted to hold a cop's gun to
make that dream come true for another
kid well
that's what being cop's all about
scenario you pull a car over for
speeding you find out that it's your
father how do you handle the situation
well first i would be like
dad
you're alive
what the hell also do you know where my
catcher's mitt is that is the dumbest
thing i've ever heard don't you just
shut up for a second what's going on
he's he's a jerk he's being such a jerk
it's an awful thing to say to his human
being are you crying no i'm not crying
okay i'm allergic to jerks okay andy
outside i don't care it's stupid
[Music]
so just sit here and do your thing do i
have to tuck my shirt in because
honestly that's kind of a deal-breaker
let her fly
i don't want you to go back to london
just remember every time you look up at
the moon i too
will be looking at a moon not the same
moon obviously that's impossible get why
you don't want anyone to know about duke
silver and you don't have to worry
your secret is safe with me
to even it out
i'm gonna tell you all of my secrets oh
no that's not necessary i once forgot to
brush my teeth for five weeks i didn't
actually sell my last car i just forgot
where i parked it i don't know who al
gore is and at this point i'm too afraid
to ask when they say two percent milk i
don't know what the other 98 is when i
was a baby my head was so big scientists
did experiments on me i once threw beer
to swan and then it attacked my niece
rebecca that'll do andrew i just had a
big meeting with my new advisory board
and they're brilliant and amazing
they're real killers
leslie
i tried to make ramen in the coffee pot
and i broke everything
thank you andy i'll be right in ron and
diane sitting in a treat
k-i-s-s-i-s-s-i-p-p-i
do you hear that bird i need a few more
volunteers andy will you be iceland the
bad guys for mighty ducks too don't
think so okay how about japan the bad
guys from karate kid too
even worse how about germany
they've never been the bad guys why
don't you be finland okay okay and i'll
be the moon
i can't believe we're at hogwarts
no that's buckingham palace
hogwarts is fictional do you know that
it's important to me that you know that
andy are you okay oh i'm fine it's just
that life is pointless and nothing
matters and i'm always tired also i
can't sleep i'm overeating none of my
old hobbies interest me
ever since andy failed the police
academy exam his self-esteem has hit
rock bottom
he's always sad and sweaty
he's usually happy and sweaty so andy
tell me about the night you fell into
the pit oh yeah that's actually a great
story um i just finished up a gig with
my band three skin formerly foreskin but
our bases left for personal reasons and
i was taking the shortcut home and i
thought i saw
a toaster lying in the pit i was like
maybe i should get that
and i fell in
and broke my legs such a tragedy why
would you want a toaster that's lying at
the bottom of a pit i don't know i was
pretty wasted
you